hey everyone it's Mike from order
flows.com and here is my orderflows
market analysis for Thursday February 16
2017 and it was an interesting day you
know we we opened up we went low we
opened up we went lower and then you
know we rallied came off again and we
closed up near our highs I mean S&S were
still down marginally like a couple of
points Dow was up seven um another new
record high so it was quite an
interesting day and some interesting
things in the order flow in both the
bonds and the Eis and you know we'll get
into that in a second first a brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only and should not be considered a
solicitation a buy or sell a Futures
Contract or make any other type of
investment decision Futures Trading
contain substantial risk and is not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results the tools
in this presentation are the orderflows
trader which is the footprint chart the
Volos flip the U-turn and the transition
so let's jump in I I'll start with the
uh e- mini3 range chart here let me let
me pull it up real
quick got a bit of a cold coming I think
um Le I got a stuffed up nose
um it's uh so here this is the E mini
this is the three range chart and around
you know Cash open at 8 uh you know 8:30
we're trading at that time around 48 and
a half 49 in that area and then you know
we're start going sideways then we get
this big push lower um you can start
seeing it pick up in here you know when
we're going sideways you got you know
buying IM balances selling IM balances
you know 700 selling 719 buying 885
buying 474 you know selling buying
buying um and then if you right here you
start noticing selling only selling only
selling only selling only you know and
we're starting to move down okay what's
going on you watch the Delta you know
1,800 now you know 1 1200 1800 2,000 we
coming into this low look at this volume
here
3500 2,300 and look at the time it's
happening very fast know it's just very
strong selling going on into this low
you know when you're coming into the
lows you know are we how can you tell if
you're going to make new lows well if
you're coming in there very aggressively
meaning you know everyone's just piling
in hitting the bids and you got
imbalances chances are you're going to
go lower and you do over the next couple
minutes here you see um I mean look at
this Delta minus 4,000 here got another
imbalances imbalances here you got some
buying some volume went through here
actually at uh 44 and a quarter you know
5,000 on the bid 5,000 on the offer but
still we powered through that making
these lows boom boom boom you get down
here you have a Divergence positive
Delta of a th000 you have uh a ratio
pounds low although this you know the
numbers here are kind of small you know
if if you're doing a ratio bonds low
you'd want to see higher numbers and
then you start moving away you got ratio
ratio ratio blue number blue number blue
number and you know that that's what you
like to see right you got a Divergence
with the ratio so you're seeing hey you
know at this time I remember looking at
it thinking hey you know maybe we can
start to uh you know maybe this is going
to be our low for the day you know this
is kind of a weak ratio bounds low you
know some I hate to call this stopping
volumes because but the numbers involved
are kind of small but you know it's a
ratio so it deals with the the
mathematics of the
numbers and what happens is you know you
got four ratios in a row then comes
right back down you got selling uh you
got this you got a selling balance of
1300 but you know it's in a spot that
you'd expect it to be you know on a down
candle you expect it to be here just
like you had here and here just like on
blue candle on green candle up you got
it this spot this spot this spot and you
started coming down you got a selling
imbalance here stack selling imbalance
you got negative Deltas um know 1100
1500 at this time this Market is is it's
rocking and rolling you know it's
putting a lot of volume
through and you know normally I I to me
this is very bullish right here honestly
um you know we got three ratios in a row
you got a Divergence and you know I'd be
looking for a pullback in this bar it
happened here so you know where normally
what I'd be looking to enter in is
somewhere between this bar uh this point
of control and this third bar and this
point of control here so you know around
the 44 44 and a half area somewhere in
there but then problem is you get down
in here and you got this very negative
thing here you got this selling
imbalance which is not not what you want
to be seeing you know if you're getting
along so you got a bid in here you got a
bid in here your Stop's just going to be
below this low and you know so that's
going to give you about a point stop
point in a couple tick or two so maybe
about six ticks um but you know you be
looking for that if this is going to be
your low you know you're looking for a
big move up so you know are you willing
to risk six ticks for you know five
points and then what happens is you just
go sideways in this imbalance test the
low here um you know honestly you know
if if I in this position I'd be just
looking to get out after this imbalance
um you know we don't get stopped out but
it's just hanging around in there I
don't want to be sitting here um hoping
that the Market's going to go back up
you know it it should have made that
move already it should have pulled back
in here then made that move instead
we're pulling back in here through there
you know through your your area that
you're looking to get long in here and
you just go sideways um you know it's it
really loses its Effectiveness you got
the selling imbalance stack selling
imbalance and you just trade in it over
the next four bars five bars then you
start pulling up a little bit but then
you know it's just going sideways you
know you got this again you're getting
some very good volumes in here and you
know the Market's not going anywhere and
we do make another low you know so if if
you stayed in that trade you know
looking for a move off this low you
would have been stopped out because we
made a new low here um you should have
been stopped out and then again you're
getting something it's kind of bullish
here you got some nice volume 2300 4,000
you've got a ratio here
28 and another ratio here. 31 you know
get ratio bounds High ratio bounds
low point of control at the bottom you
know i' be looking maybe for you know if
you know at this point the way this
Market's moving is it's moving pretty
good A very decent volume sometimes it
moves pretty fast you know here's 920
920 921 so you know you're basically tra
a three range Target it's almost like
you're trading in minute bars or or 30
second bars in some cases and it's
moving kind of fast but nevertheless you
know I mean normally I would see
something like this I would like to have
a Divergence you know if I'm buying off
the low with the ratio but you know this
is bullish you know this is bullish I
see these numbers here you know I'd
probably be looking to take a chance on
it and you know it just goes sideways
over the next uh the next 5 minutes it
does turn around start going up you know
about 15 minutes later this is at 9:20
by the time you start you know putting
in a little bit of a rally it's already
940 so it's around or 9:34 you know so
you're you're already coming into about
uh you know 20 minutes 15 minutes 20
minutes at this point and you
know that that's not a good sign I said
you're trading a you know the way the
Market's moving back at this time right
919 920 920 921 said it's moving very
fast and then it just slows down here
and then you know then you you'll see
it's uh not until here that it really
starts making the move so and then what
does it do it just goes sideways then we
start coming into the low again got
another stacked imbalance
here then you get a bullish ratio which
you know is not what you want to be
seeing right after this imbalance
stacked imbalance and then this is nice
to get you know a a bearish ratio then
another bearish ratio but you know by
this time I I I don't like fighting in
here I I don't like it where it's in the
third bar normally I don't like it when
it's in the third bar like this but you
know the one nice thing it's got going
forward is it's got a ratio ratio here
ratio bounds low ratio bonds low so it's
indicating you know some price rejection
up and you know up you know around this
442 45 and above area we do come into
the lows you know selling it balance
right there another selling in balance
at that low um you know selling is
strong I mean look at these Deltas going
into as lows 2400 you know above it 1,00
2,800 and we just keep powering down
into those more selling imbalances boom
boom 1,00 1600
2400 another we got this time we got a
Divergence here at uh at this low nice
positive Delta 2,000 no ratio
though and it just comes right back you
know you get a little bit of a bounce
okay so you know here when we're running
into these those we don't have
divergences you know
which you could take it either way um
you know you know is it a sign that
we're going to keep going lower or not
it's hard to it's hard to say um but you
I would have been nicer to see you know
one or two divergences you know in
addition to this one here before we're
going lower um but you you're seeing
this is how you want to see these lows
you know very strong negative Deltas you
know here it's Max Delta zero here Max
Delta zero a lot of zeros in the in the
max Delta meaning you know there was
there's no positive the bar was never
with positive Delta um then we start
moving off this low okay you like I said
no Divergence this time you know but you
got th positive here 600 1,500 you know
when you're looking for the market to
move off of a low yeah you want to see
nice positive Deltas you know building
up you know it's you know 1,000 is nice
600 yeah that's good I I'd prefer a
higher number you know 1500 is good 1,00
so this right here this looks good you
know that hey we could possibly move it
off and then it just comes right right
back down um so unfortunate you
know ratio bounds High ratio bounds High
you know ratio
ratio especially here you know you
couldn't string more than two together
here you had some nice positive Deltas
but then it just gets up to this bar
where it just flattens out 262 know then
here it's minus a th000 now I I don't
like that it just sort of flattens out
you know if this number was higher you
know that might be another story you
know if this bar was green that might be
another story minus a th000 right at
this sort of Swing High you know with
the ratio then the ratio afterward again
with a nice strong Delta um you know as
you're going up you know even though
this is 1,00 positive Delta which is
stronger than the previous bar 1500 you
know 1,800 and then it gets small 200
and it's
negative you'll make it negative th000
and again it's negative th000 so you
know if I had gotten along in here I I
mean I wouldn't because I'll be looking
at this that's I I like that you're
building up some positive Deltas but
there's nothing else besides that um to
really tell you to get long you know you
start coming down in here again you're
thinking okay maybe we're going to come
into those lows right you got 1,000 900
3,000 and you get this one bar right
here point of control right at the
bottom you know now I often say you know
when you get the point of control right
at the bottom you know that's decent you
know pick up decent sign of some
stopping volume
but on a day like today you know you're
just getting some huge
volume going through at at at each
prices you know so thousand yeah it's
decent I don't know if that's going to
be enough to stop this move if we trade
back down to it I want to see what it
looks like then we start working our way
back down you got to sell and imbalance
this time so there wasn't much left
there get through it another selling of
balance another selling of
balance at this point I'm thinking hey
you know we're going to go um lower and
we do not by much you know go a tick
lower and then another tick lower um you
know just sort of tick lower tick lower
here now this is where starts to get a
little bit interesting here you got a
ratio bounds
low 3 very nice volume down here 2500
you know whereas you know before you
know when you're seeing these lows yeah,
1500 is good 77 not much you know even
this point of control at the bottom with
this ratio mod is a th000 you know
earlier we had a ratio bounds
low um back here what was it oh that's
that's different one um this one you
know but the volume numbers involved you
know it's 54 124
592 whereas you know we're coming into
this low times those on 10 it's 2500 so
that's decent you know that's a decent
number then you get you know Divergence
as well which is nice and next bar you
got another ratio balance low although
you know it's. 26 this one
is.3 these numbers you know it's closer
to zero but these numbers are a bit
smaller so you know I mean it's nice to
get but then I I don't like that you're
run into this ratio bounds low here then
another bullish ratio so you get you
know bullish ratio bearish ratio bullish
ratio bearish ratio once you if I'm
looking at it like
this to me that's a sign that hey you
know I don't know what's going to be in
the next bar but I have a feeling if we
start alternating this stuff you know
this this Market's going to go sideways
and it does you know it goes you know
down up bar down bar up bar then we
start moving away from these lows here
okay you get to this one um this is the
Delta scalp we're giving a cell um look
at that volume in there 5,000 right so
you know people you know
5,794 um you know people were buying
5,000 Lots at that price you know
and normally you know you're thinking
[__] you know that that's a heavy volume
there we're going to come off but if you
don't you got to ask yourself you know
what do you know well you know you got a
strong buyer there someone to support
the market it so which ways what are we
going to do we going to stay above it or
stay below it in this case we just sort
of hang around it over the next what
time was that 1025 1026 you know over
the next basically half hour um you know
it's sort of trading around back and
forth get up to the swing High here
start coming off nothing major um you
know even in this area we're still you
know this area where was
it you know that's 41 and a quarter I
think it was 41 and a half 41 and a
quarter um you know we're sort of
trading up or down through it you know
more or less trading around there um you
know for for a while and it's not until
a bit later where was it here you know
even you know now again you know this is
already uh you know 1:00 you know we're
still in that area and then we're still
putting some decent volume you know 2300
you know and we're still going back and
forth so we make another I say push
lower but you know we get below that
level sort of hang around there then you
know this is just before 2:00 when
things really start uh you know picking
up and you know this
is the Delta surge right I've got these
indicators Delta surge you can download
for free okay um if you download it for
free just restart your ninja Trader
after you do don't send me an email
saying hey it doesn't work you it works
on data that as it comes in but you have
to after you install it restart ninja
Trader so it can read the data coming in
it doesn't work on past data you want to
do it on pass data go into Market replay
but anyway um I just say that because
you know people don't read the the
instructions that come with it that says
first line I put on there now is please
restart ninja Trader second line is it
doesn't work on historical data because
it needs to read the bid offer data as
it's coming
in and you know this is your clue here
you know you're sort of going back back
and forth and Al it picks up this these
signs in the Delta you know before you
know look at these Deltas you know you
get a couple positive couple negative
couple positive now you're starting to
see a Delta
pattern here which is telling you you
know buying is picking up you know
selling is possibly stopped and and
buying is picked up you know and and be
be alert to catch it you know so you
know this is 21 this is that same area
right 20
2341 and a quarter 21 341 and a half um
let's just draw a line
there here okay all right I mean you'd
be getting long somewhere in this bar
ideally so you'd be looking around 42 41
and a half I going get long at 41 and a
half but you know 42 41 and
3/4 again this is that area
earlier right here right remember that
volume that support there so again I'm
not saying that this buying is coming
back I don't know you know that was what
time when did that happen that was at
uh where was it here it is uh 10:26 you
know and then now it's like
2:00 you know just before 2 right here
you know that's telling you that hey you
know buying is is starting to dominate
this time you know before it was going
back and forth it would go up and go
down buy and selling was kind of mixed
you know that's what the market does it
this area around this 43 uh sorry 41 41
1/2 40 1/2 area that was an area of fair
price you know where people are happy to
buy around that price you know people
were happy to try and sell a little bit
above it try and buy a little bit below
it you know trade around that area and
you know now it's it's telling you that
hey you know we can start to move away
from this this area you know buying is
taking over selling is not as
strong and you know we couldn't start to
make a move and then you
do you got another big imbalance in here
selling imbalance so now you know this
is a couple ticks higher you're seeing
some you know some active bidding here
5,000 2000 sorry 3,
2,700 even in this area here 3,500 and
then so if you're looking to be getting
long somewhere in here so we'll call it
42 you know and just be patient you know
you get up to the cash
close you know up here the cash closes
and here 46 you know so you're talking
Four
Points you know then you know takes it
to the end of the day basically so you
know that was the that was the nice
clear sign you know for you if you're uh
if you're watching the
snps okay so the bond market this
morning know this is coming into the
morning it was overnight was very tight
um you know about
15032 up to about 15016 so pretty tight
range uh you know overnight and you get
into the 8:00 we make new lows here you
nothing special in these lows um you
know we got a Divergence there you know
I can't really read much into it here
you got a here you got a ratio you know
you got a ra Divergence with the ratio
but again you know
it's very tight range you know I mean
you got your low here you made a new low
at uh was that 31 I believe your high is
still uh 5015 so it's basically you know
16 tick range
um you're buying it going right back
into the middle of the range um you know
could you have done it yeah would I do
that probably not you know I'd be
looking for more of a sideways action
but you know what if you
did good on you you know we did start
trading right up into the highs started
making new highs here you have a
Divergence no no ratio afterwards in
this bar instead it just turns right
back on you and keeps going
higher um get higher here three here's
three in a row 1 2 3 and you know this
is a setup that I I talk about in in the
course and this one you know
it you got this is what it looks like
textbook example almost um you know
ratio ratio ratio it doesn't you know
this ratio bonds low ratio bonds High
ratio bonds high as long as it's three
blue numbers it I don't give
a I don't care if it's um you know ratio
bonds low low high or rati bonds high as
long as it's three blue ratios that's
all I'm concerned about then you get the
fourth bar here you get a
pullback you know a down candle and you
you're looking for an entry somewhere in
between this point of control ideally
and this point of control and it gives
it to you right here it pulls
literally um you know to that's where it
pulls down to in between you know these
two points of controls and you know so
that's where you'd be looking to buy and
your stop would be you know below
here and then we go higher um you know
we take out the high I say we go higher
I mean we take out the high by another
tick and then you know this is where it
gets interesting then you get a negative
you know you get some selling
information up here so at this high is
the high of the day
and you have a Divergence you have a
ratio bonds low even in the next bar
you've got a ratio balance high so you
got another another ratio right here
whoops so you got you know blue number
blue number you got the Divergence you
know you should be looking to get short
off this bar you don't necessarily need
to wait here you pull right up to this
point of
control you know which is where you'd be
looking to get short you know your stop
would just be right up here and then you
you make a nice move down from you know
the 0 03 area down to you know the 28s
get a little bit of a pullback and then
you get another bearish ratio here a
ratio bounds low telling you hey you
know what there's some volume up here
stopping then he moves
higher and then you continue lower I
mean honestly you know if I was in this
trade I I wasn't um you know this is
where you'd be looking to get short you
know somewhere in here around this point
of control me personally I probably
would have taken it down this you know
20 28 um you know usually the bonds I I
I don't now try to stay too long in the
bonds especially now you know there's a
lot of volatility in these markets me
I'm more of a hit and run short-term guy
but this bar right here is is giving you
you know confidence to to stay short or
you know I don't say get short some more
but uh this enough here
is if if I was in this position and I
didn't cover it I would like to you know
this is what I like to see here um you
know even though it's green and it's
going up I like to get a a bearish um
setup here and then we go lower down to
this uh 20 was that 21 price rejection
ctor gives a buy here and then we start
you know on on your way back up and we
make some new highs up
here now you got sort of the same thing
going on here this this time though
you've got a uh Divergence you don't
have a ratio it's six right 6.2 you know
I want a blue number and you get one in
the next bar and I often say you know
even if you don't get it in the the bar
within Divergence look to the next bar
if you get it in the next
bar go for it and then you know this bar
here we trade right back up to that
point of control you know this point of
control is going to be your
resistance and what do you do you just
you sell off from there so there was two
nice opportunities in the bonds today
you know they they set themselves up
well um very little heat that you know
the trade didn't really go against you
that
much so I'll take a look at some other
charts here real quick all right this is
the uh I'm going to go through these
indicators again I'm showing you know
they work on the order chart I'm showing
them on the bar charts so it's a little
easier to see you know so you don't get
caught up in the in the numbers but uh
again even it's a 987 tick chart why I
have a 987 pick chart up is because you
know somebody a couple years ago said
hey you watch the orderflow on a 987
tick chart it's you know it's good to
look at okay honestly I've never
bothered um usually I look at range
charts but you hey if it works it works
you know who am I to I'm not the type
that's just going to shut everything off
you know there people out there that say
oh I have a way of trading and that's
the way you have to trade no you know
I'm always open to other ideas you know
exchanging ideas um I mean that's how
you grow as a Trader um you know you
don't grow when you shut everybody else
off so you know cash opens you know this
is 8:30 right in here you know boom this
is the transition setting three 100
400 and you get a nice move here um you
know from this 40 48 area down into the
44s you know get another another signal
here you know pulls back a little bit a
couple ticks before continuing down this
one failed okay you know don't throw
stones at me say oh this one failed you
suck you're an idiot you can't do
anything right come on I just gave you
you you just had a nice winner here nice
winner there
um this one no probably would have
stopped you
out um you run a little back and forth
here you know get a buy then a sell um
then you get another buy here this one
works out nicely again you know from the
42 is 43 is area
up until the close you know where we
closed at 46 so um you know you could
trading with you know a couple points of
stop you could do fine you know I mean
it's not like every trade you're ever
going to have is is going to be a winner
you know you you ideally what you want
is your winners you know bigger than
your losers and keep your losers small
okay here's a euro currency this again
is 987 tick
chart um you know
7:00 gives you a little buy Here 7:30
just you know 7:15 you get a sell
um up here you get a sell they probably
would have gone against you here stopped
you out up here you get another sell
signal up in here and look at it you
know from it's know this 10680 area up
in here down to the 60 area before
turning around and coming back up um you
know this is 10:00 1010 you know over
the next two hours basically comes down
into the 60s you know that's a 20 point
move in the euro currency you know and
you could have got something here um I
know people will send me nasty emails I
got short here and it stopped me out up
here I mean come on you know if you
getting short at
7:15 you got it's in your money in the
favor for an hour all a sudden starts
turning on you and you don't take
profits I don't know if you should you
know consider trading you know I mean
part of trading is understanding when
the Market's turning you know people say
well you know you indicator didn't tell
me to get out here part of trading is is
making these decisions you know Everyone
likes to make things automated I'm
working with somebody on some automation
for
these but at the end of the day I mean
in the guy also that I'm working with on
this you know he agrees he also hates
automation but really what we're trying
to automate is the order entry to get
you in as quickly as possible so you can
watch you know more
markets then you know then you could
just manage the trade right and that's
where you know that's where a lot of
people make their money is on trade
management not necessarily having the
the greatest entries in the world or
greatest exits it's the trade manage it
managing the position once you're in it
um you know that that gets lost a lot of
times in in trading people just think
well I I just need the perfect entry and
the perfect exit well you could have a
you're never going to get perfection in
trading um you're going to get you get
good but you're never going to get
perfect you know people always you know
people come to me thinking you know
orderflow hey I read a lot about
orderflow I watch a lot of your videos I
watch a lot of competitors videos you
know orderflow is where it's at you know
it's going to change me as a Trader
well to change you as a Trader you have
to want to change you know people don't
want sometimes people don't want to
change I find the best people that come
in are the ones that come in and share
their ideas um sometimes I don't
necessarily answer doesn't mean I'm not
reading your ideas but um you know
there's you know I got a Facebook page
you know I got this YouTube channel I
got my blog I put a lot of my ideas out
there and part of the reason I do that
is get other get you guys thinking on on
stuff don't think you're going to come
in and trade exactly like me I don't
expect people to um you know I spent 20
years trading at a certain level in a
certain way and you know I've met a lot
of people along the way and has
developed my own style of
trading you know when people come to me
asking me to help them
trade really what I want to do is you
know get them also to think and pick up
the get the things from me that that you
know is going to help them trade um like
I said you I don't expect you to know
everything that I know I mean that would
be ridiculous but you know if if in our
conversations you could pick things up
about trading then you know great I mean
not everything is going to resonate with
you you I can't make you sell in a
position you know in a time when you're
looking to buy um you know it's I joke
about it but when I was going through it
I was teaching my wife how to
drive you know I'll be like okay she
trying to rever first Park I'd be
telling you to turn the wheel left you
know when she's turning the wheel right
and you know we're get a big argument
and finally I said okay do what you know
you got to do what you got to do I I
can't force you I can't put a gun to
your head to tell you to turn the wheel
I mean you know if if you have to turn
the wheel in a certain direction first I
guess you got to do that I I can't
change that um even though it's wrong
but you know we all have bad habits uh
so anyway I I digress already but let me
uh take take a look at one or two other
charts here real quick okay okay real
quick this is the flip this is a 10
range chart setting the 5 and
25 nothing's you know nothing it
probably would have if you got into this
trade probably would have just stopped
you out you know maybe you could have
managed it a little bit gotten out I I
think I would have taken the full loss
um it did go up then sold off but that
was the only signal on the 10 range mini
Dow chart all right this is the euro
currency yeah this a one minute chart
and there's times when in the euro
currency on a 1 minute chart honestly
you know this transition it works
brilliantly there's times where it
struggles and this morning yeah again
I'm not really interested around 6 you
know after 7 really is what I'm
interested um you I'm still in my sleep
mode there that time just going through
stuff 8:30 get a sell signal didn't work
out you know I often you know lately
I've been talking about you know if
you're unsure of a signal let the market
Lead You In you know meaning you get to
sell signal here you know let the market
start selling
off you over the next four or five bars
you know watch it you don't have to
react instantly hey I got to sell I sell
you know I I hear these stories of these
guys with their trading rooms and
they're just in there get short get
short byy here by I'm long I'm in I'm in
I'm out okay like that I mean come on
um the only time I've seen Traders like
that
is on the trading in the pit you know
during the
major economic number and even that you
know
is that's not you know I joke when I see
these movies on trading and every you
know every time they go on the trading
floor it's complete
chaos it's not like that in in real life
you know once in a while it does get
chaotic but most of the time it's very
orderly trading um so anyway you know
let the markets you know come in and and
get you in so you know if you're patient
you know start waiting okay let me see
if the market can take me in on this it
didn't okay
so you wouldn't take the trade here you
know this got this big down bar okay is
it going to continue let's see over the
next couple bars it just sort of hangs
around there then boom here you get the
nice big down bar telling you hey it's
going to continue get this nice move
down this one had happened a little bit
quicker started getting some negative
signs there some selling coming in here
now this one did go up and then I think
it would just you know stopped you out
in there
unfortunately
um you know earlier this week you know
after 10:00 it just went sideways at
least here you got a little bit I'll say
a little bit of activity but you know 60
up to
85 this one yeah kind of worked out this
one I don't think you that that's not
enough for me for a move you know and
after two I'm not looking to trade the
euro
currency okay this is the last chart
here for today this is the mini do 100
tick chart you know this is a chart that
I like looking at again mini doll should
be trading it during the after the cash
open
yeah you got a couple signals here 7
just before
8:00 this one is right boom on the cash
open um you get a lot of volume coming
in the cash open I
don't I I like to let it wait I like to
let it settle down you can see here 830
831 832 it's still trading in there this
signal failed this one didn't work this
one didn't work I was thinking ah [__]
It's a lousy day um at the big down
candle then you know at least there was
a r hope here this one worked out quite
nicely um you know from this five you
know 585 590 area all the way up to
610 before just sort of going sideways
and working its way back down again um
the cell worked its way down it's a nice
trending
down um you know if you're trailing your
stock you know you're not getting out up
here you should be getting out up over
here so you could at least had something
out of that trade um again I'm not
saying you would hold it all that come
all the way back up here then go back
down no should be traing your stop and
getting out somewhere down here rather
than up here and I'm not saying you'd
take it hold it all the way back against
you I mean some people do should not
whatever um now that's not prudent money
management but uh you know I can't say
anything about that this one you know it
started to come off then It reversed on
you pretty
quick um you know these you know came
down a bit here before turning up this
one straight up uh left time over here
11 you this one worked out again it came
off pretty sharp and then started to
Rally you know each these days you know
with this Market
it's you know today was a we spent a lot
of time negative territory it it felt
like uh you know I supposed to positive
territory you this one you worked out a
little bit before turning around on you
this one started going down then you got
a buy here which didn't work out um now
we're coming in 2:00
area and if you remember it was just
straight up uh if you remember the snps
you know from basically from 2:00
actually s& PS was from 1:00 but um you
know here you're getting to buy around
just after
2 and you know I don't know what you
want to call that
580 all the way up you know to the 595
where you get a sell um you know but
that's right ahead of the cash close and
then cash closes so you know anyway you
you seen the flip the in the transition
and the orderflows trader I mean you
know the orderflows trader is the main
software which you know if you can learn
how to read that you know really put you
ahead of a lot of the other Traders out
there so thanks for watching this to
learn more about the trading software
used in this presentation and how you
can profit with it from orderflow visit
my website www. orderflows decom and be
sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
so thank you and hope to see you on the
inside